your baby your [ __ ] makes people crazy
crazy I'm sorry whoa stop stop
retraction you were already oh man
they're gonna [ __ ] oh god I want to
tell also what's been going on with us
so she was her first love me everything
I'm already love it so he has this
god-awful fungal infection in his foot
that's been there for about three years
let me see it let me see it no I know
wait hold on a second ago you were
sitting with your feet like the rain
foots fine yeah that's that one's fine I
don't I don't show cases one so lately
in the last six months every time that
we've ever had sex I've just it's just
been really really a chief for me like
after we okay like discharged almost
like a yeast infection doctors like no
it's not a yeast infection because you
they can look at it under the microscope
immediately while you're there okay and
the guy was like no it's not Candida
okay is thinking I look at him when he
just you know I just observe him as he's
you know sitting on the couch or playing
on his and he's always scratching his
feet okay especially with his right hand
and eyes you're brighter right so every
time we have sex and he actually touches
me with his right hand or touches me
with any hand at all that happens but if
we only have just straight on [ __ ] and
dick yeah I don't like no touching right
no had sex but he is in denial he
doesn't think that he's giving me some
type of 100% it's you Bobby and I'm not
even just saying that to take kalila
side like let me tell you something so I
just went to this holistic doctor and
she tested me it's called muscle testing
it sounds like total hocus-pocus and I
wouldn't even believe in it if it didn't
happen to me but I had an infection on
my nipple that lasted for seven months
oh my god and I went through three
rounds of antibiotics I got an
ultrasound like I went to three
different doctors and they didn't know
what it was they were like we don't know
why it's happening sometimes these
things happen
and I finally I went to this holistic
doctor for something else and she was
like oh is there anything else wrong
with you and I was like actually my
nipple has been infected for seven what
did it look like it looks like a
Whitehead on just one and I would pop it
and it would go away for a day and then
come back and it was like it never grew
it wasn't it was just always this
Whitehead it looked disgusting but it
was small enough that it didn't show on
camera but like so this holistic doctor
she's like alright we're gonna do some
muscle testing so she had me read out
loud this list of all these different
bacterias while she clicked my feet
together and like I I was just like the
whole time I was like this is [ __ ]
like I can't believe I'm doing this this
is [ __ ] and then finally like I read
one bacteria name which sounded like
something out of like Harry Potter what
is it it was like no I don't even it's
like you would probably know it honestly
but I had no idea what I was saying and
she was like that's it that's the one I
work I was Hogwarts
Bob Warren I was like Hogwarts and she
was like that's it that's the one your
body is telling me that's the one and
then she put all these men I know I know
I don't even believe it either but it
happened to me and then she put all
these magnets on me and left me like
that for 20 minutes and then I'm not
even [ __ ] kidding you the next
morning it was gone and it never came
back
do you think it was coincidence or do
you really think it was her Doctor Doom
[Laughter]
it was her and it wasn't the power of
positive thinking cuz I was thinking
very negatively like so I have to go to
the forum I know her yeah I'm gonna give
you know [ __ ] you [ __ ] you I'm not
putting magnets on what it is
it's got I have foot fungi yeah I know
what it is so then stop pinching it as
much of your girlfriend's [ __ ] that's
disgusting I don't touch it I just stick
my dick in I go like then I'm with the
sound with the sound as well
[Music]